we are learning new details about the
stunning twist in a Good Samaritan
murder story that made national
headlines
it happened in December and the initial
reports said that Jacqueline Smith was
stabbed to death while giving money to a
panhandler but yesterday Jacqueline's
husband and his adult daughter were
charged with her murder
police now say that they staged this
attack Jericka Duncan is in Baltimore
with more on this story jurika talked
about a plot twist good morning to you
good morning such a crazy story you know
Jacqueline and Keith Smith were married
in 2014 and friends and family said
looking from the outside they seemed
like a loving couple but those friends
and family also say that when they
learned about the details of
Jacqueline's death they did not believe
her husband's story a Texas judge
arraigned 52 year old Keith Smith and
his 28 year old daughter
Valerius Smith Monday after they were
charged with first-degree murder police
say they were arrested in Texas Sunday
authorities were concerned the pair was
trying to flee over the Mexico border
it's a stunning turn of events from
December I jumped out the car to run but
I heard my wife scream as Smith
initially told police his wife
Jacqueline an engineer was trying to
give money to a panhandler at a traffic
light when she was robbed and stabbed to
death in an emotional press conference
with his daughter by his side he said he
watched the attack unfold the car was
they took my wife's life I hope it was
worth it because you're gonna be asset
to that one day you wanna answer to
authorities now say it was all an act
was not a panhandler and that the
circumstances were very different
Jacqueline's brother Marcel Trevino says
Smith story was suspect from the
beginning it was automatically do you
know what this story don't sound wait I
asked him like you know well why did you
put the window down you know and you
know he said he hit the Autobot and then
it went down automatically and then I
said well you know why he didn't you
know step on the gas and drive off and
you know I froze
Jacqueline's mother Anna trevean I know
it was Boni I didn't believe her husband
at all
I knew something else happened
the story garnered nationwide attention
Mayor Catherine Pugh called it a black
eye for her city this person had
actually used our city to do this kind
of violence in a city that's already
struggling with its own issues and and
people really worried about how we
continue
Jacqueline's brother says the family is
still in shock
she put her trust in her hot you know
she gave her heart to somebody who
obviously didn't deserve it
Marcel says he affectionately called his
sister no risk Jackie he says because
she was strong she knew what she wanted
for herself and for her sons
police are not giving any details about
a possible motive and we're hearing that
the two suspects are expected to be
extradited back here to Baltimore in the
coming days fionna hopefully her brother
can get some closure now Jericka thank
you